folks in the US and around the world
have watched Ferguson Missouri in shock
sumit said the American suburb looks
more like a war zone in a developing
country even calling it Ferguson but
guess what
Ferguson is actually pretty all-american
Ferguson is not unusual it is a
reflection of American life in just
about every way imaginable high
unemployment rates high dropout rates in
school underfunded education programs
police harassment before you get to a
Michael Brown death before you get to an
international outcry of protest you
still have a city that is wrestling with
the various forms of inequality that
every city in this nation is so just
what does that inequality look like in
America and how are blacks particularly
affected well first there's poverty 15%
of the country lives in poverty in 2012
but for African Americans the poverty
rate was almost double that the story in
Ferguson where 2/3 of the population is
black is basically the same 1/4 of the
population in st. Louis County which is
home to Ferguson lives in poverty
african-americans were also twice as
likely as White's to be unemployed
across the country for most of the past
six decades and back in st. Louis County
black unemployment was actually three
times higher than white unemployment in
2012 one factor driving inequality in
Ferguson and the rest of the country
segregation yup even though segregation
laws were overturned decades ago one
study found that cities across the u.s.
whites typically live in communities
that are 75 percent white and in cities
with large black populations like
Detroit New York and Chicago blacks are
equally isolated in Detroit blacks on
average within neighborhoods that are 81
percent black Ferguson fits right into
this pattern with a 67 percent black
population not only is segregation bad
for understanding one another it has
hurt communities of color when it comes
to banking housing loans and more and
even in places with majority black
populations you still have what Marc
Lamont Hill calls white power structures
in Ferguson the mayor and the police
chief are white as is the overwhelming
majority of the police
another way Ferguson is a true
reflection of American life arrests and
incarcerations there are four times more
black arrests and white arrests in
Missouri which pretty much matches
national incarceration numbers black men
across the country were six times as
likely as White's to be in federal state
and local jails in 2010 US law
enforcement has a long history of
targeting African Americans which is why
many say they don't feel they're getting
equal protection under the law that plus
everything else you just heard is why
people in Ferguson and across the
country are fed up and for anyone who
thinks that the police crackdown there
is new or foreign look this historical
reminder from Evan Hill sink in what
you're seeing is actually pretty
American so if you're an American are
you disappointed with the United States
and if you live elsewhere does this
change your perception let us know in
the comments subscribe on YouTube follow
us on Twitter and like us on Facebook